well President Joe Biden flew down to
Florida yesterday and met with a
republican Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
and they did a soda sort of assess the
damage and comfort people type event
after Hurricane Ian a devastated Florida
and I don't even want to deal in this
segment with Ron desantis's hypocrisy
wherein he's previously in Congress
voted against funding for disasters like
for superstorm Sandy in New York and New
Jersey and then is begging for the money
in Florida we've already talked about
that that's not new ground so I don't
want to focus on that what I want to
focus on is how either uh I mean listen
reluctantly reluctantly Ron DeSantis
praised Joe Biden and the federal
response to the hurricane indicating
they gave us everything we asked for Joe
Biden praised Ron DeSantis and even
though DeSantis had a Sour Puss on his
face the entire time
um it proves that these people can work
together and on so many issues there
really shouldn't be any disagreements
the disagreements are basically
contrived for the voters to feel as
though my guy is doing something so
anyway let's look at a couple of Clips
here here is Ron DeSantis again with a
scowl on his face and a sourpuss saying
Biden's handle this fine this general
area we were very fortunate to have good
coordination uh with uh White House and
with FEMA from the very beginning of
this we declared a state of emergency
last Friday September 23rd this wasn't
even this was a disturbance out there by
Colombia and then the next day we got a
major disaster declaration approved by
the president and we really appreciated
that and that basically set off the
massive mobilization that we had ready
to be able to respond to this storm so
thanks to Joe Biden they were able to do
everything he felt they needed to do as
of now there have been over 2500 rescues
affect you okay so there's the DeSantis
sort of like yeah yeah yeah it was all
good uh here is more a praise to some
degree from Ron DeSantis of Joe Biden
and I think we've worked as well across
state local and federal of any disaster
that I've seen and so I want to thank
administrator Criswell from FEMA for
being on the ground uh being supportive
and being very responsive I think one of
the things that you're seeing in this
response we are cutting through the
bureaucracy we are cutting through the
red tape wow and that's from the
Democratic president letting you cut
through all of the bureaucracy and red
tape to get you what you need that's
pretty good local government state
government all the way up to the
president so we appreciate uh the the
team effort so there was like a really
strange feel to the entire thing
um here is President Biden also praising
DeSantis which again
fantastic I I'm these seem like genuine
genuine compliments I think it's a great
thing
so difficult to hear but Biden said he
and DeSantis have worked hand in glove
it's been great he's been dealing with
the crisis well
um and then another just really
interesting moment here was when
President Biden was praising Governor
Ron DeSantis and says one of the great
things that's happened here is we've
recognized there is such a thing called
global warming
what the governor's done is pretty
remarkable so far
he's done in terms of you know it's it's
uh you know first of all the biggest
thing the governor's done and so many
others have done they've recognize this
thing called global warming right the
world is changing yeah and descent is
not thrilled to have to sit through that
for sure and the reality is Hurricane
response is very different under Biden
than it was under Trump here is Trump
you might remember shooting paper towel
rolls like their basketballs not long
after being very confused about whether
Puerto Ricans or American citizens in
the context of one hurricane response
then he showed up and shot paper towels
like basketballs and it's all fun and
games for Donald Trump so certainly
different now here's my my big Takeaway
on this
this is a reminder
that so much of the partisanship really
is contrived now there's two
perspectives one perspective on this
would be now the partisanship is real
and both Biden and DeSantis have to kind
of turn up their noses and uh hold their
breath and sort of Praise each other
begrudgingly DeSantis is definitely
begrudging in his praise of Biden but
not because I genuinely think DeSantis
is unwilling to praise Biden it's
because he knows it's going to hurt him
with his voters if he Praises Biden too
much Biden on the other hand seems to be
having a grand old time with the fact
that hey guys listen there was a time
and and Biden was involved in politics
when it was the case where it wasn't
controversial that on something like a
Disaster Response and many other issues
even foreign policy issues in many cases
Republicans and Democrats are basically
United and worked together Biden
actually is part of that era where that
was a thing and so the takeaway for me
is so much of the nonsense that we deal
with where oh there's a pandemic well
let's all band together and just do the
oh wait you're not gonna do that you're
not going to do that oh okay here we
have a foreign policy situation and
let's just all we're on the same page
that Vladimir Putin Owen we're not on
the same page a lot of it is completely
contrived at our deficit to our uh
dismay as voters and the people they
could be completely United and take out
of the political realm so much of this
stuff so very interesting to see it and
one particularly interesting moment when
Joe Biden dropped an F-bomb I'm not
going to spend a ton of time on this but
there has been this viral moment
yesterday when President Joe Biden flew
down to Florida to survey the damage and
to make some announcements alongside
Republican Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
where Biden drop than F-bomb and said no
one FS with a Biden and of course a
bunch of Republicans are like oh this
isn't presidential this isn't the right
tone to be striking Huffington Post
article uh president on hot Mike with
Florida official no one F's with a Biden
he made the comment during what looked
like a laid-back exchange with Fort
Myers beaches mayor while touring the
area damaged by Hurricane Ian
Biden was recorded uh one of the this
was one of the areas hit by the
hurricane Murphy can be heard Ray
Murphy's the mayor of Fort Myers Beach
Murphy can be heard thanking Biden for
coming to the state before both
officials exchanged the phrase keep the
faith and then Biden told Murphy no one
efts with a Biden so let's take a look
at the clip and we do have to bleep it
because we're on radio and television
and we don't want any FCC problems for
our stations but if you want the
unedited version it's easy to find
it
[Music]
outside the house that's exactly right
that's exactly right all right good to
see you
thank you guys all right so a bunch of
right Wingers oh this isn't presidential
this isn't how a president should speak
imagine thinking this is a problem so
first of all
first of all
this actually is the real Biden right
remember the classic when President
Biden was vice president and they signed
Obamacare and Biden was on a hot mic
telling Barack Obama this is a big
effing deal he's just enthused
enthusiastic in that way it's the real
Biden which I appreciate there was the
Peter Ducey SOB hot mic incident
[Music]
that's a great asset more inflation
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] okay and so
you know all the right Wingers have to
do their dog and pony show about its
Unbecoming of a president and all this
stuff if your belief was that one of the
great things about Trump was that he
talked like a so-called normal person
and he told it like it is and he said
what's on his mind and you don't have
some fake reverence for elite media
people and all of that stuff and it's
good when Trump does it how can we
possibly believe you're really upset at
Biden dropping an F-bomb give me a break
guys it is so pathetic and contrived
that we shouldn't even really give it
attention and so I'm not gonna spend
more than the two minutes on it that I
already have this is Joe Biden this is
one of the things I actually like about
Joe Biden in the context of lots of
things I don't like so much it is
absolutely implausible that these right
Wingers are actually upset about this in
this way and if they are they're
complete in total Hypocrites let's take
a quick break and we'll be back right
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right so Donald Trump spoke
yesterday in Miami Florida at a Hispanic
leadership conference called the afpi
Hispanic leadership conference if you
put Trump and Hispanic folks together
something weird is bound to happen and
this is one of the strangest speeches I
have ever seen Donald Trump give Beyond
bizarre super glitchy his skin almost
matching the red step and repeat behind
the lectern everything about it bizarre
I have never seen Trump's brain glitch
this badly here is the first uh example
Two glitches in one sentence Trump
trying to talk about during his
anti-trans rant saying without parental
consent he calls it parental consult and
then in trying to say he will oppose the
Biden Administration he says
administrating and every time it happens
he looks disoriented it's that
glitchiness and Trump does not look good
folks so teach you should ever be
allowed to teach transgender to our
children without parental for himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administrating at this this
Administration
the Biden administration's sick plan to
require yeah visibly disoriented and
then at another really strange moment
Donald Trump seemingly stumbling on what
the U.S population is confused about the
American population and kind of turns it
into a rant about immigration to try to
save himself and just really looking
confused up there we'll never be behind
China even though they have slightly
more people than we do like about a
billion more
they have 1.5 billion we have actually
our country is so crazy now we don't
even know how many we have we have any
idea because I believe the number of
people that came into our country and
will come in this year is 10 million
people not 3 million could even be 12
million people we have absolutely no
idea what it is so it's hard to say how
many people we have because we have no
idea how many people have come into our
country illegally
but we as you can hear this the crowd
sitting completely silently and I don't
know if that's the most interesting rant
to a group of Hispanic leaders at
another moment Donald Trump told a
completely Bonker story about how if he
ran against George Washington and
Abraham Lincoln he would defeat them by
40 percentage points in some
hypothetical time traveling election I
believe I remember a very famous
pollster very well-known John McLaughlin
came to my office just prior to the play
coming in he said sir if George
Washington and Abraham
Lincoln sir
came alive from the dead and they formed
a president vice president team you
would beat them by 40 percent
what did the brain statements okay I
mean it it's so dumb it's like you can't
even fact check something so stupid uh
and the idea that that's what a pollster
is telling him it's like you lost by a
record number of votes to Joe Biden who
as you claim ran a campaign from his
basement how embarrassing you're not
defeating George Washington and Lincoln
when you can't even beat Biden
campaigning from his basement give me a
break dude it doesn't make any sense
Trump then ranting about the Mar-A-Lago
raid and Trump says he's thinking as he
speaks here and that's a really
dangerous thing for Trump to do
you know they spend all their time on
nonsense the FBI nonsense raiding
Mar-A-Lago let's let's raid Mar-A-Lago
but leave the cartels alone how about
that
I think I think of this I'm just
thinking as I'm speaking
you don't mind if I go a little off
script no but I think they raided
Mar-A-Lago but the cartels they they
have their own mar-a-lagos and those are
fined leave them alone let them continue
to destroy it's interesting likening
Mar-A-Lago as the physical center of a
crime family two cartels that that's
actually pretty fascinating and as as
you all know when Trump's on the
teleprompter it's a disaster because he
can't read it and then when he's off the
teleprompter doing the free association
it's bad because none of it makes any
sense whatsoever uh here's one more clip
where Trump says the raid at Mar-A-Lago
has given him a lot of free publicity
and what can they should be penalized
very severely for it the banks have let
the community down I think they've let
the country down Biden is not only
wrecking our economy he's destroying the
rule of law
you probably read and heard about the
document hoax has anyone heard about the
document hopes helicopters flying over
Mar-A-Lago
well they've given us about five billion
dollars worth of free publicity that's a
nice house
if it weren't so nice they probably
wouldn't be doing it because horribly
not as he says and then last clip here
just total stream of Consciousness
verbal inkblot horrible because we'll
make it prosperous again because we
don't take our oil that's under our feet
Pamela right we don't take what's under
our feet I call it Liquid Gold we go to
them to get far inferior product that we
refine in the United States you know we
have the only refiners because what they
have is tar right it's very rough it's
not light and it's hard sweet it's rough
stuff and they talk about the
environment so they go into Venezuela to
get stuff that's really bad it's refined
in the United States so if there is
anything goes in the air it goes in the
air in the United States right but even
if it went to another country it blows
over the whole thing is so crazy yeah we
don't even know what you're talking
about it's so crazy what they're doing
is so crazy so we're begging Venezuela
we're begging Saudi Arabia we're begging
everybody for oil and we have more than
everybody yeah remember the truth of the
matter is that domestic oil production
has actually increased under Joe Biden
from where it was under Donald Trump
slightly it's a small margin the data is
publicly available and you can find it
so really not looking good is Trump here
visit confused and making very little
sense and the crowd seemingly
recognizing it sitting in complete and
total silence the Herschel Walker story
is becoming dare I say completely
kafka-esque so earlier this week the
story came out
of a woman saying Herschel Walker claims
to be against abortion he says abortion
is murder in his Senate candidacy in
Georgia but he urged me to get an
abortion when he impregnated me and he
paid for the abortion and after that
story came out Herschel Walker denied
even knowing who the woman is saying he
doesn't know saying he definitely didn't
pay for anybody's abortion and uh that
that's part of why the story is made up
because he doesn't even know the woman
it turns out based on new reporting from
The Daily Beast that the woman in
question is someone that is actually
already the mother of another one of her
Herschel Walker's children and this just
blows the story wide wide open it is an
unbelievable new development in the
story
and I later we're going to play Bill
O'Reilly's advice to Herschel Walker and
to some degree Bill O'Reilly's advice is
making sense which is he may just want
to come clean on this she had an
abortion with Herschel Walker reads The
Daily Beast headline she also had a
child with him Herschel Walker has
claimed he has no idea who the woman
could be here is why that is surprising
and Roger sullenberger for The Daily
Beast writes there's a good reason the
woman finds the defense that Walker
doesn't know who she is highly doubtful
she is the mother of one of his children
folks the story is falling apart
the article writes when the woman first
told The Daily Beast or story we agreed
not to reveal certain details about her
identity over concerns for safety and
privacy then Walker categorically denied
the story said he didn't know who was
making the allegation Wednesday morning
Fox host Brian Kilmeade asked Walker did
you figure out the woman's identity not
at all Walker replies and that's what I
hope everyone can see it's sort of like
everyone is anonymous or everyone is
leaking and they want you to confess to
something you have no clue about Walker
called it a desperate attack and on and
on and on the anonymous woman said the
defense sounded ridiculous sure I was
stunned she said but I guess it also
doesn't shock me that maybe there are
just so many of us he truly doesn't
remember but then again if he really
forgot about it that says something too
the woman told The Daily Beast her Chief
concern with revealing her name was
because she is the mother of Walkers one
of Walker's own children and she wanted
to protect her family's privacy
Walker has publicly acknowledged the
child as his own and the woman proved
she is the child's mother and provided
evidence of a long-term relationship
with Walker
it's one of the mothers of one of his
children remember that Walker went on
the Hannity program and answered about
whether he knows the woman in This Way
start with The Daily Beast Herschel I
mean serious accusations that in 2009
that you paid for an abortion first
question do you know the woman that is
making this allegation
I have no idea no idea but it is a
flight out lie yeah he has no idea a new
interview with Hugh Hewitt where again
he says he doesn't know who the woman is
so just to put a bow on it do you have
any idea who this alleged former lover
of yours is who says you paid for an
abortion on father to child any idea
whatsoever I have no idea at all and
that's the problem is you know uh when
they said I had the kids that I was
hiding a lot of people don't know that
this same reporter found out that this
was not true never wrote a retraction
never said anything they just let it go
it went on and that is of course untrue
Roger sullenberger didn't write a
retraction because the story is accurate
that he originally wrote about Walker's
kid and
um Walker actually acknowledged that as
well
unbelievable implosion it is not only a
woman who was impregnated but then had
an abortion at Walker's request she also
birthed one of Walker's kids and 24 more
hours is probably all that this story
has given that the pressure is really
mounting on Herschel Walker let's look
at new polling in Walker versus Warnock
now I want to remind you most of the
polling here is still pre-abortion
Scandal but the race has already turned
in Raphael warnock's favor and that's a
very good thing since yesterday there
have been two new polls there is a Fox 5
Insider Advantage poll which has Warnock
plus three and then there is a wxia TV
survey USA poll which has Rafael Warnock
plus 12. these are the only two polls
currently that include any of October
but what's really important is that the
survey USA poll by the way survey USA
has an a rating on 538 the survey USA
poll includes some October but 95
percent of the poll was conducted before
the abortion bombshell story involving
Herschel Walker these new numbers still
don't fully include
um the full effect of the Herschel
Walker abortion story and if you look at
the chart you see the red line Herschel
Walker almost a vertical decline while
Raphael Warnock is benefiting from this
decline this is not about using personal
dirt to hurt candidates this is about
Walker has no business being in the
United States Senate and the Georgia
voters are so weaponized by the
disinformation that has been shot at
them that they don't know Up Is Down
Down is up day is night they don't know
what's going on and they are using
special pleading and they are using
selective enforcement of their supposed
values to continue saying I like
Herschel Walker it seems as though some
of them
some of them are bailing by Monday by
Monday my prediction is the polling will
put walker even further down but in the
meantime we assume nothing
everyone must vote don't stay home
etc etc one last thing on the Herschel
Walker stuff Herschel Walker appeared on
Fox News he was asked why did your own
son come out against you that was really
damaging to your campaign as many of you
know we covered that Christian Walker a
right-wing influencer who is Herschel
Walker's son denounced Herschel Walker
said he would threaten us he tried to
kill us we had to move six times as a
result of his threats he's a fake he's a
phony all these different things
Christian Walker denouncing his own
father Herschel Walker appearing on Fox
News being asked about it and his answer
is completely incoherent he's doing
tremendous damage to you by coming out
with those statements do you know why
he's saying this
well the damage he's doing is letting
people know that they're left would do
whatever they can to win this seat and I
told you when I got in this race I'm
going to win this seat people see
someone sitting here in front of you
right now that's been redeemed and I
want America to know I'm living proof
that you can make mistakes and get up
and keep going forward but you can only
do it in this country right here and you
can only do it if we get this election
correct this come November what What on
earth does that have to do with your son
the Democrats his son is a public Maga
right winger his own son has decided to
tell the country my dad sucks for lack
of a better term that has nothing to do
with Democrats and this absurd rambling
answer I have to tell you on the one
hand
this has to be extraordinarily difficult
for Herschel Walker and I empathize with
that to see your son turn against you in
this way but it also has nothing to do
with Democrats what so however but maybe
the saddest thing about it all is many
Republicans who just don't want Raphael
Warnock to be the next senator in
Georgia or to continue being a senator
in Georgia better said since he's the
incumbent
that wild rambling nonsense that we just
heard from Herschel Walker
they'll probably accept it and that's
good enough for them and say Hey listen
he addressed it did he he talked about
Democrats his sons are Maga right winger
everybody makes mistakes
of different degrees but to not own up
to them and again it's not a mistake to
pay for an abortion if you're coercing a
woman to get one that's a different
story and that may be part of the story
but the mistake of staking out a
completely dishonest public position
that goes against everything that you
have going in your life privately and
then lying about it and then not
admitting that that's what happened it
does show a lack of character and a lack
of conscience and to blame it all on
Democrats who have nothing to do with
your own son turning against you is
really pathetic again I think we have 24
to 48 hours left of this Scandal before
a complete implosion I expect Walker's
campaign to be all but over by Monday
we'll have these clips on our Instagram
find us on Instagram by searching
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Bill
Keller who was the founding
editor-in-chief of The Marshall Project
and also author of the book what's
prison for punishment and Rehabilitation
in the age of mass incarceration bill I
really appreciate you being on today
thanks for having me so I mean I guess
to start with at least in some
theoretical sense prison sentences in
the United States are supposed to be for
rehabilitation right the idea that uh
someone has um done something wrong
harmful to society and or to victims
they have been sentenced to some amount
of time in prison and that that
experience the time that they spend in
prison is at least to some degree
rehabilitative in addition to being
punitive so that then they serve their
sentence they come out and now they're
rehabilitated right I mean at least sort
of theoretically can you talk about
whether in practice any elements of the
criminal justice system in the U.S
actually function in that way
not really I mean you can find
individual programs that function that
way some of them experimental some of
them more broadly based like college
education programs that actually do
rehabilitate but there's
there are a number of obstacles one of
them is cost it's expensive to do
Rehabilitation programs
you know you need trained personnel and
so on
one of them puritanical streak I think
in American culture uh
the main objective from that point of
view and Rehabilitation is just
pampering
also prisons are not the most ideal
therapeutic environment they're scary
they're noisy
the people who believe some are really
cops not therapists or social workers
they don't have the training to
administer those sorts of programs
so there's there are a lot of obstacles
the heroes of my book if I can call them
that are the
the directions and visuals who are
trying to improve rehabilitation in
spite of the obstacles and the teachers
the volunteers the
you know kind of a mystery
uh it's why I chose to wrote about write
about prisons rather than courts or cops
because
there's been a lot of attention
deservedly paid to policing
judges and prosecutors for the most part
run for public office and do a lot of
their business in public
prisons are kind of a mystery uh so
that's that's why I wanted to focus on
that if we um put aside for a second
when there are actual rehabil
Rehabilitation programs the sort of
status quo day-to-day of being in your
standard prison
at this point we know beyond any doubt
that's not a rehabilitative experience
in any way is it and in fact it could
sort of be the opposite
no that's absolutely right there's
considerable research
um by people like Bruce Western and
Colombia who show that the pro that
being incarcerated can actually make you
more likely to commit crimes when you
get out right
and and when we when we say that I mean
there's this sort of general idea
prison can turn you into turn you into a
more hardened or violent criminal and
it's often repeated but what sort of
what sort of data do we have about that
well the one piece of data that's kind
of shocking is that
two-thirds of the people who were
incarcerated
will be rearrested within five years of
their release
the recidivism rate it's a tricky metric
and then people measure it different
ways but the recidivism suggests that we
are not doing a very effective job of
rehabilitating overall
when we talk about
um the deterrent effect of
um the system that we have and the idea
that at the end of some crime that one
commits if you are caught and charged
and convicted there could be a
punishment that's coming
from what I've read Studies have found
that the death penalty as compared to
life in prison without parole
does not seem to be a functional
deterrent in terms of reducing the
crimes wherein one would be eligible for
such punishments what do we know more
generally about prison sentences and the
deterrent effect on those not in prison
there's a sociologist named Francis
Cullen at University of Cincinnati who's
done a lot of work on this subject and
he he makes this logical argument that
the deterrent effect assumes that before
you commit a crime you stop and consider
the risks
in a sort of logical way whereas a great
majority of crimes are either
opportunistic that are done in concert
with you know going along with a gang
um they're spontaneous and to the extent
that people do stop and consider the
consequences before they do something
illegal they're they're mainly
considering the chances of getting
caught right it doesn't make a
difference to them whether the
punishment is five years for a felony or
20 years for a felony that that's just
not the way people think
yeah you know we were talking about
jaywalking yesterday on our program
because of the California governor
Newsome recently signed into law
um a bill that that mostly
um decriminalizes jaywalking and I think
that there there's sort of some gray
area in the sense that like you know I
jaywalk all the time and it is true that
if I knew that life in prison was a
possible sentence for jaywalking I
wouldn't do it but you need these really
extreme examples that that in order to
really be able to make that case whereas
as you talk about with many crimes
murder in particular murders are are
such a type of crime where already
you're talking about only a fraction of
the population is even willing to commit
a murder based on the research we have
that the line between life in prison
with no parole and death penalty for
example it seems like it's a completely
different type of consideration than my
jaywalking example
right I mean I would never say that that
the risk of going to jail or
being severely punished doesn't figure
into anybody's thinking at all I mean
the deterrents exists but it's just
greatly exaggerated and you weigh that
against the
the effects of being incarcerated
to commit another crime
uh it's not it's not a convincing reason
to lock people up especially to lock
people up as we do for far longer
periods of time and for lesser crimes
than most other countries yeah I want to
talk about that next so can you give
some specific examples of average
sentence in the U.S for certain crimes
compared to in some other countries for
which we have data for the same crime
sure
sorry I just lost my train of thought
yeah any crime that you that that we
could think of a a difference in average
sentencing between the U.S and other
countries oh I know what I was going to
say this mass incarceration is a
relatively new phenomenon for us I think
that's important to remember
that for most of the 20th century
incarceration rate in the United States
was something like a hundred people
incarcerated for every hundred thousand
population which was a little higher
than the rest of the world but not not
off the tracks
and then it's beginning in the 70s we
took the sharp right turn
and it became more like 500.
people in jail for every 100 000 in the
population I mean that's an incredible
phenomenon and part of that is
that we incarcerate people for much
longer periods of time most
I'm talking here about developed
countries mostly the European countries
the ones that I've taken a look at
most countries don't have a death
penalty they don't have life without
parole
um
in the book I talked about the case of
Anders Breivik who's in the Norwegian
mass murderer who
slaughtered 70 some kids at a party you
know political party picnic
and instead of just 21 years now if he's
deemed to be a danger to society a judge
can extend that but that's
a severe that's the maximum punishment
right
yeah are there um you know sometimes
there's this idea that if you do the
European style of incarceration where
conditions generally speaking are better
and sentences are shorter
uh that there's a higher recidivism rate
but it doesn't appear to be borne out in
the data is it
no there are citizen rates in all of the
Scandinavian countries in Germany and
most of the developed world are
considerably lower than ours
so to me what that says is that for some
of the folks in the United States who
are demanding the stricter prison
sentences I don't really think they care
bill about the rehabilitative effect or
the LA the odds of recidivism I think
there's a sort of you did the thing and
now you deserve a strict punishment
there's kind of this strict father
morality aspect to it that's totally
untethered from the actual impact what's
your sense
that's absolutely right there are a
couple of reasons why we should care
even if a lot of people have ever
hard sell animals there's a I guess
moral reason that Americans like the
profess that we believe in second
chances and Redemption uh and so if we
want to live up to those ideals we
should be
treating prison inmates as if they were
redeemable
but beyond that there's a pragmatic down
to earth self-centered
argument for rehabilitation
every year we let out six hundred
thousand people from state and federal
prisons
uh do would you rather have those people
emerge from prison brutalized alienated
stigmatized and lacking in any kind of
skills that will help them re-enter the
real world
or would you like to have them equip
these citizens Neighbors
missing argument
yeah it seems the the preferable answer
is is clear on that
um to talk a little bit about the the
kind of society that is created within
many prisons you know I um I interviewed
the author Ted Conover who wrote This
Book new Jack in which he actually
became a great book he became a
corrections officer
at sing-sing in New York and talks about
his experiences and he did it knowing
his plan was ultimately to to write a
book and he talks quite a bit about
the reality of the sort of culture
around being a corrections officer in
the United States and the pressures
faced systemic and and otherwise and he
doesn't excuse any of the behavior that
he observed when he was uh in the job
but he sort of gives a glimpse into the
realities of how the corrections officer
circumstances impact how prisons are run
as well can you talk a little bit about
that what what is unique in the United
States about being a corrections officer
and the expectations and the pressures
if you want to be a corrections officer
in Germany
you have to take two years of college
level courses including things like
human rights law psychology
sociology
and then you're
your job is essentially to be a
therapist is putting it a little too
strongly but to engage
the inmates
to try to figure out what it was that
made them go wrong and see what programs
would be available to address it
if you're going to become a corrections
officer in the United States and I'm
generalizing broadly here there's a
saying in Corrections that if you've
seen one prison you've seen one prison
everyone has its own kind of culture
yeah
but for the most part if you're going to
become a corrections officer as Ted
conover's book demonstrated you're going
to get a few weeks of training mostly
about crowd control and self-defense
it's it's a it's more of a paramilitary
organization
it's
as Ted emerged from that experience with
victims of the environment and the
culture
too
and I think there's some truth in that
yeah and it seems to some degree oh
sorry Bill I was going to say there
seems to be a mirroring in one of the
things that it seems many police
departments would benefit from mirrors
something that Corrections Officers
would benefit from as well which is more
training along the lines of of sort of
Social Work and relationship building
and Community Building
yeah and you can find
leaders of organized
Corrections Officers unions and things
who will say that that's
in the last 10 years or so they've begun
to talk the talk a little bit
unfortunately they're organized in the
states that have really strong
Corrections Officers unions
they tend to be source of resistance
that's a good job
one of the things that is uh more unique
in the United States is this concept of
a for-profit prison run by a corporation
that contracts with various agencies and
sometimes those contracts include a
guaranteed occupancy where even if there
is not actually a certain occupancy the
prison operator gets paid as if they
were so they have a certain uh
expectation of guaranteed Revenue that
they're going to be receiving can you
talk a little bit about even though most
inmates in the United States are not
held at for-profit private prisons what
is particular or unique to the
for-profit prison experience in the
United States or is it the same as in
the state-run and federal prisons
foreign you know there's another book by
a journalist who went undercover as a
prison guard Shane Bauer's book
and he went underground in a Louisiana
prison that was a private owned by
Corrections Corporation of America and
he he does a nice job first of all of
demonstrating that
the bottom line becomes a big factor in
in the thinking of those prisons
but also the whole history of
incarceration in America
it has various profit motives associated
with them starting most and most
egregiously with the South where prison
labor became a substitute for slave
labor
without much improvement in the
conditions and certainly without any pay
so it seems as though it's essentially
quite similar but with the profit motive
added on top of it I mean is that fair
to say
yeah that's that's I think that's fair
to say it's actually you're right in
saying that it's a small
percentage of the incarcerated
population who are in privately run
prisons but that misses a
familiarity services that even the
state-run prisons contract for people to
mod make phone services available to do
medical care to do transport
to run the cafeterias often those are
contracted after private
companies that don't have any incentive
to
to do more than they have to
also there's elements of privatization
even within State and federally run
prisons as well I did not know that
correct
one example that's been a big issue
lately in a lot of Prisons is
there's a company that makes available
tablets
so that you can download books for your
your class and and communicate with
as a general rule prisoners don't have
access to the internet but they can get
limited services on a tablet
but the company's charges
exorbitant rates for the
use of them and
then they barely have any opportunity to
earn the money to pay for them
yep and that's we've seen that also with
the with exorbitant phone rates and
prisons as well uh Bill uh we've been
speaking with Bill Keller who is the
author of what's prison for punishment
and Rehabilitation in the age of mass
incarceration Bill very interesting and
I really appreciate your time today
well thanks for having me on I'm glad to
spread the message
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's look at a couple other
interesting uh Clips there was an event
with Christian supporters of Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker now
Herschel Walker claims to be pro-life he
claims that abortion is murder he claims
no exceptions for the woman whether it's
rape incest or health or none no
exceptions ever
and he has now been credibly accused of
urging and paying for an abortion for a
woman uh with whom he allegedly already
had another child and the right Wingers
and the Christians you would think that
they would say wow well this guy really
isn't for us instead they held a prayer
for Herschel and his wife they
apparently believe that these attacks
are coming from the devil they rebuke
the devil this is utter Insanity take a
look at this
amen if we call forth your ministering
Angels
yeah and we ask you to rebuke the devil
it's the devil's fault not Herschel
walkers
hey you know maybe if these values are
so important to you Christian supporters
of Herschel Walker maybe focus on the
fact that he lied to you about his view
on abortion rather than blaming the
devil so we thank you that we can
support our fellow conqueror yes
the one that we are praying for today we
lift up his wife
is sensitive to all of these attacks
yeah all of the things the enemy will
dredge up and throw an instance God make
her stronger
this is this is not a satire this is
real I hope people understand
backbone of Holy Ghost steel
faith will be stronger than it's ever
been before yeah so they have renewed
faith in Herschel Walker these are
hypocritians hypocritical Christians
this wasn't the work of the devil this
was Herschel Walker's own doing and
Herschel Walker's own lying and
dishonesty and by the way praying for
the guy after we learned not only about
this entire abortion Fiasco but his
ex-wife and son had to move six times in
six years due to the alleged acts of
domestic violence from Herschel Walker
against his family and they're praying
for Herschel what's Christian about that
and again only if you're so deluded and
also by the way willing to suspend
disbelief in a way where you say none of
this stuff is true what's true is that
the devil Satan apparently sent by
Democrats Democrats have Satan on a
hotline apparently send them in any time
that's who's to blame here this really
is sort of like the cherry on top where
there is no reasoning with these people
now why do I think the polling continues
to shift away from Walker if his
supporters are like this they're not all
like this there are more casual
Republicans in Georgia who they don't
like Warnock but after this they're not
going to vote for Walker Independence as
well and that's why I believe that the
next round of polling that we get will
probably know it by Monday Tuesday after
the the Monday holiday I believe that
Walker will be even more underwater than
he already is a Bill O'Reilly failed Fox
News host Bill O'Reilly has come out of
the woodwork with advice for Herschel
Walker and I promise this is it for
Herschel Walker's stuff for the week
unless something insane happens it this
is really it for Herschel Walker stuff
this is more about Bill O'Reilly Bill
O'Reilly put together some advice for
Herschel Walker that I have to tell you
in some way makes sense which is a weird
thing to say about anything Bill
O'Reilly had to say take a look he's
been on this program I know him a little
bit
but every two weeks there's another
Scandal about Herschel Walker and the
latest one is that
um
he had a girlfriend and he paid for an
abortion
for the girlfriend
now
the news agency to put that out is a far
left
revolting news agency
The Daily Beast actually does some
pretty good reporting but okay you know
it's like okay
and Walker went on Hannity last night
and said this go I never asked anyone to
get an abortion I never paid for an
abortion and it's a lie and I'm going to
continue to fight you know I'll tell you
that's what they want they want this
seat
okay
here's what you got to do Herschel and
and I'm just talking to you like a human
being here please this is a serious
accusation
if you did it
you got to say it did it I don't know
how you do that but
you can't lie about it especially at
this point how do you do it if you did
not do it
then you got to go after The Daily Beast
you got to have your attorneys sue them
and if there is a person alleging that
she had an abortion you got to see that
person yeah now remember that Herschel
Walker three days ago said tomorrow
morning we're filing a defamation suit
as of this moment no such suit has been
filed and that's a really common thing
that happens in the sort of celebrity
and politics space which is you say
you're going to file a defamation suit
but of course if it's true it's not
defamation and as Michael Cohen
mentioned when I appeared on his program
we recorded an episode
if filing that lawsuit opens up
Discovery and you might end up getting
deposed and so you really don't do it
unless it's actually defamation
if you did not do it and you have to do
that now
so that the people in Georgia who are
going what the deuce is this right every
two weeks we got another child father by
Mr Walker or this or whatever but if
this is not true
then your lawyers have to mobilize now
yeah and why aren't they and you have to
hold a press conference with your
lawyers and you have to say this is
false imagine Herschel Walker trying to
read a statement at a press conference
and going completely off the rails never
happened and we're going to file this
Against The Daily Beast now if you do
that and indeed if you did not pay for
an abortion then that will turn that
race around hmm you'll win your seat
maybe because Georgians will see you
rightly as a victim of this smear
but if you did it
you lose right even if you admit you did
yeah so I mean Bill O'Reilly's kind of
right here only insofar as Walker
doesn't actually have to admit that it's
true
but if he doesn't and he keeps denying
it in increasingly less credible ways
and we learn more and more about the
alleged truth and that includes that not
only is this woman someone who had an
abortion after being impregnated by
Walker but is also the mother of one of
his kids it's going to become a very
difficult story to credibly deny so I
have to say to some degree
Bill O'Reilly giving some sensible
advice we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P uh unfortunately
there are people we launched the the
David packman show Finance Channel we're
right at the cusp of 10 000 subscribers
on it already youtube.com Pacman Finance
it's a beautiful channel it's Financial
education but someone seems confused
about what the channel actually is
[Music]
all you saying sir that people should
tune in and you will tell them exactly
how to invest every dollar that they
have and you are a financial genius and
you have made great money on doing this
I remember you saying that and by the
way I'm just kidding I'm so sick of your
reading comprehension challenged
conservative listeners I know who call
in and think they catch you because they
made up something in their head it's
like driving me nuts I'd say come on
people good God I mean this isn't even
actually reading comprehension listening
comprehension yeah but uh now we can see
why they're so easily exploited
that's the conservative sheep not you
exploiting them thanks for all the fun
stuff have a good weekend I'm just
calling just because I'm too lazy to
write all right very good and uh again I
am not giving anyone specific Financial
advice on the Pacman Finance YouTube
channel but we do have a ton of
Education topics you can find the
channel at youtube.com pacmanfinance we
are like within 20 subscribers of 10
000. so if you want to be one of the
first 10 000 check it out recent Clips
include what is your net worth how do
you simply create a basic personal
balance sheet to figure out what is your
net worth
um why is it that we have seen a
declining stock market over the last
several months what factors influence
that how do you improve your credit
score why you should not try to time the
market that's one of the most popular
clips and most controversial I don't
think you should try to time the market
I don't think it's really doable for the
average person and quite frankly even
most money managers fail to correctly
time the market a lot of really good
stuff no Politics on the channel okay
that's youtube.com
pacmanfinance I hope that you will all
join me on today's bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad well yeah I mean we're
funded by the audience so in a sense
it's true that with a bonus show makes
money okay Alex uh you can sign up at
joinpakman.com we will talk about job
openings plunging in August is that a
good sign or a bad sign there's two ways
to interpret that a Michigan judge has
dropped felony charges against seven
people in the Flint water Scandal and a
U.S appeals court has sent a DACA case
back to a lower court to consider a new
rule and the implications for DACA
recipients are significant all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
don't miss it
foreign